the first look at robbie ray this season
who makes his 2021 debut after a great
spring and being shut down for about two
weeks
an era under two with 18 strikeouts and
those four spring starts that cover 13
and two-thirds innings
he gained 15 pounds of muscle and it
showed in the spring he was throwing
harder and longer with excellent control
well here's stanton with one hour
has really played well over at first
base
you know what he did there he played the
ball off to the side
and i think your hands are quicker when
you play it off to the side there watch
robbie ray fall off the mound so he
doesn't really have a chance for vlady
to flip it to him but he plays it off to
the side great hands cloudy guerrero has
worked very hard for louie all spring
long hot coal i mean 13 strikeouts and
no earned runs that's a pretty good
start and uh j fan uh he wasn't a blue
jay fan he was a yankee fan we've seen
the pictures when he was a young kid but
j fan he likes pitching against uh
toronto he's uh too few two or fewer
earned runs and all three of his career
starts and this is interesting to me
michael if this continues a little
different mix
you know about his fastball you know
about his breaking ball but he's using
his change up a lot more percentage-wise
so far this year see if that continues
here's bloody guerrero he's swinging a
hot bat as well he's hitting four
straight
balls through the right side that's
going to sneak into right good but shuts
around second he'll go to third
guerrero does it again
with two strikes he takes that inside
out swing both buchet and guerrero for
an oppo against garrett cole vladimir
guerrero jr has now reached base safely
in all 10 games this season the corners
are going to come in the middle of the
defense is going to stay back if you're
randall gretchen just put the ball in
play in the middle of the diamond on the
ground that'll score a run towards his
short fields and throws across in time
with the blue jays take the one nothing
late as beshette comes in to score
give rando grichik his ninth rbi of the
season rowdy toles he's off to a bit of
a rough start oh for 21. he's hit right
back up the middle teles has his first
hit and that was a bullet right over the
head of garrett cole into center field
so rowdy teles is on the board
eric cole had to chuck and duck on that
one that was a knuckle curve ball and
look at vladi he said hey that's his
first hit let's get the baseball
he never misses a trick look at him now
he's spotted just teasing rowdy just
teasing nobody first in second here's
alejandro kirk strike three kirk down
looking second strikeout for cole well
much better pitch there i mean that ball
hit just on the outside corner on the
bottom of the strike zone by heroes
palacios and the pitch is caught on him
is
blew him away upstairs at 98.
so that's the third strikeout for cole
the first and second two out marcus
simeon is a right hand header and rich
cut out of mystery
and he struck out simeon swinging so he
struck out the side did cold we've drawn
a lot of but the yankee offense
completely shut down by robbie ray as we
go to the fifth they do not have a hit
here is clint frazier oh strike three
looks like a curveball there dropped in
there and he throws click fraser there's
rugnetto
and there's his first hit under the
glove of guerrero down the right field
line
palacios will fire the ball in
and odor picks up the first hit rogie at
first base here's higgy
who fly to center his first time that
one is driven
deep to right center field that ball is
gone
a home run for higashiyoka
a two run blast and the yankees are up
two to one
the home run stroka and the yankees take
a 2-1 lead well we've said this since
kyle has been up and down from the minor
leagues he's got power you miss with
that fastball it's gonna go for a long
way his first homer of the season and
here is bechet who scored the only run
for the blue jays that was in the first
inning struck him out swinging the
yankee record for most strikeouts in the
first three starts of the season is held
by david cohn
he had 29 in his first three starts in
97 so a strikeout here would tie cole
skye three eight strikeouts for cole he
has another one two three and if he
leaves he'll have left after retiring 15
straight battles higashiyoka along with
cole the heroes of this game higgy hit a
two run home run in the fifth and he
swings gives a high drive to left center
that ball is high it is far it is gone
and hit off the scoreboard way in back
of the stands another home run
kyle
makes you smile
higashiyoka the home runs stroka and the
yankees take a 3-1 lead what a night for
higgy fifth home run against the blue
jays 12 in his career so he loves the
exchange rate
when you see that two-seamer up in the
strike zone it kind of sails instead of
sinks
brookie knew exactly with the sound
where that was going and there were two
on and two out
and here is vladimir guerrero jr struck
him out swinging
so o'day pitches in and out of trouble
and the yankees retain their two-run
lead now this is chapman's fourth game
and it's his first save opportunity so
he closed out the seven nothing win
against baltimore wednesday he pitched
the ninth inning a tie game against
baltimore he was one two three with
three strikeouts he pitched the
scoreless ninth yesterday in a tie game
another three strikeout inning working
around a double
so it's the first time since his 2010
rookie season
that has taken him four games to get a
save chance
and then do that
a strikeout of gorilla i think it's more
impressive to hit that than the throw i
don't know how people hit it
well this is a slider
no it's not that is a splitter and boy
it does it has movement at the end
wow
two outs runner at second yankees up by
two
strike
three ball game over yankees win
yankees win
so the yankees win on great pitching and
two home runs by kyle
hagashioka
and the yankees
win the ball game 3-2 good ball game